est-ce que ça va j'espère alors
aujourd'hui je vous parlais de samsung
aujourd'hui j'ai voulu parler de
tablettes parce que ça me saoule a
présenté deux nouvelles tablettes super
intéressante
la samsung galaxy tab est cette ff férié
dit sean et la nouvelle samsung galaxy
tab à 7 est light on a donc deux
produits vraiment différent deux tailles
différentes deux usages différents fin
du jeu différent plus ou moins ça
dépendra mais vraiment de deux cibles
différentes
on va donc regarder quelles sont ses
tablettes aussi de comprendre ce
qu'elles peuvent venir apporter mené
puis surtout on va aller faire un tour
du côté samsung pour regarder ça et puis
faut se reprendre dire ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire alors à ce
que le son soit nickel ou après ça tu
vois le petit j med qui bouge toi le
verbe qui m'aurait forcément d'accord on
le voit bien
c'est pour ça qu'il faut porter la voix
très bien le micro est loin allons-y
tu vas dire bien toi ouais toujours très
bien très bien
il ya ici chevaux on écoute on essaie de
vous accueillir de t'accueillir vallée
du possible voilà et ben c'est passé un
peu grandi mais c'est ça certains vont
se demander comment des ventes on voit
ce à quoi alors vieux arrière ouais
c'est ça donc là les nouvelles tablettes
tout à fait bon alors on commence par
quoi je te propose de commencer par la
galaxy tab est fait est fait est fait
vous avez signé de la fin d'édition
exactement écoute pour faire simple et
vous faire logique avec la gamme
smartphone on voir sur une table 7f
auquel il va élargir la famille d'état
27 alors raconte moi qu'est ce qu'il
raconte cette table cet effort déjà a pu
remarquer c'est grand talent c'est une
belle dalle c'est grâce à ça permet
d'avoir une belle surprise de visionnage
exactement donc on est sur une surface
de 12 points 4 pouces ok c'est quoi le
ratio ce que ça fait un an c'est un peu
allongé en fait rare le ratio et 16 10e
ok ça marche super donc on va pouvoir
profiter vraiment de ses séries
préférées sur cette grande table est
vraiment très grande 12,4 avec
effectivement c'est une technologie lcd
une très belle résolution également de
2560 par 1600 et du coup avec cette
tablette vous venez chercher
lorsqu'éclata 17 vous
cherchez vraiment le premium les
créatifs gens qui voulaient lieu un
produit exigeant et cheveux on garde
l'esprit de l'année 7
mais on vient gagner un peu sur le prix
exactement d'autres plutôt bien résumé
gilles bon et je les regarde bien j'ai
réalisé avant de dire qui va chercher
qui en fait avec ce produit là on va
chercher ceux qui souhaitent une taille
d'écran très grande ouais mais
effectivement avec un positionnement un
peu moins élitistes comme tu l'avais dit
aimer qui recherchent vraiment un
confort visuel optimal
ok avec cette grande surface on va
retrouver l'adn de la baisse est plus ok
12,4 également en super amoled avec
cette même surface d'affichage et
pouvoir profiter de son sont à de céder
ses séries préférées et de pouvoir
tranquillement et confortablement
consommer du contenu décor à la
différence qu'on va avoir c'est quoi ces
super amoled versus elle s'élève
exactement quatre haut parleurs versus 2
haut-parleurs quatre haut-parleurs
versus 2 hockey en termes de pertes on
nous sommes toujours sur un processeur
octo cores ok mais étend sur une
produite d'accessibilité on est sur un
processeur un peu moins performant donc
exactement comment dire mais un
processeur qui va pouvoir répondre aux
halles usage le plus fréquent vidéos
jeux vidéo
un conte peu à utiliser sur cette
tablette de quoi il ya plus sur un
produit familial et moi pour une créatif
exactement pour autant on garde quand
même le s pen way qui est aussi une
signature de nos tablettes qui inclut
avec les produits la différence c'est
que sur la baisse est plus il est
connecté
ici sur la table cet effet il ne l'est
pas mais on va retrouver tout ce qui
fait la force de ce espen le confort
d'utilisation une mine fine et précise
des niveaux de pression qui permettent
de voir de tout très précis d'avoir un
confort créatif important d'accord donc
je peux venir m'essayer à dessiner je
peux venir l'utiliser pour annoter
griffonnait travail et naviguer sans
problème exactement peut aller à jester
que je vais m'en vais avec la cette
mauvaise alors effectivement sur nos
produits les plus frais clip est aussi
on à l'application s not qui permet de
l'effectif comme tu as dit de faire une
prise de notes rapides et qui va
synchroniser sur l'ensemble des produits
samsung utilise le même
donc ça c'est hyper intéressant parce
que tu peux démarrer une note sur ton
smartphone et la continuer chez toi
confortablement avec ton espen et
tablettes
trop cool c'est vrai que c'est cool ok
ça marche niveau batterie j'ai quoi la
réussite d'avoir perçu à la batterie on
est sur une capacité dix milles 90
millions père hockey qui va pouvoir a
procuré un temps d'utilisation de 13
heures en vidéo continue d'accord donc
largement suffisant pour pour son usage
quotidien
très bien trade est alors la différence
de prix que j'ai avec mata 17 plus plus
que tu viens les compagnons autant de
taille d'écran oui on est sûr ici un
positionnement insistant 19 sur la
version 5 g ok lorsqu'on est à peu près
900 euros sur une version tabesse est
plus donc on a un vrai hein veille car
presque la moitié prix
baup à moitié prix mais voilà on est sur
un gap important et qui va voir on
l'espère pouvoir profiter à ses
tablettes et adressée aux plus grands
noms ceux qui recherchent des tailles
d'écran élevé et on sait qu'ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux sur le marché
français il ya trois micros 1-6 6-1 sur
le côté et un de ben ouais pour la
vision pour la vision puisque la caméra
frontale et ici au milieu et cette
caméra permet ferment de faire de
l'enregistrement et de la vidéo au
travail télétravail efficace ok et puis
également cette c3 micro permettent de
réduire les bruits environnants de 50%
ont ce pouvoir être plus efficace
également en vision bon c'est pas cette
caméra qu'on va utiliser pour faire les
photos souvenir familial c'est pas une
caméra qui ferra peut-être les plus
beaux souvenirs c'est une caméra
d'appoint qui permettra de prendre le
cliché sur l'instant on another
exactement ok ça marchait conclut sympa
et la table à cette lettre c'est autre
chose c'est un plus petit format c'est
pas exactement la même population qu'on
va venir ciblé pas exactement les mêmes
personnes mais tout autant efficace
telle lettre qu'il ya plus heureux
destiné à un usage familial puisque la
femme est cet effet on est vraiment sur
quelqu'un qui cherche un grand écran là
on est sur une tablette qui va pouvoir
bénéficier au plus grand nombre au sein
de la famille pourquoi pas scoré sur
déjà un produit qui à un tarif à moins
de 200 euros 180 euros et qui permet en
fait aussi de bénéficier d'une très
grande surface d'affichage dans un
format compact soient combattus là on
est sur un
un format de 8 7 pouces ouais donc dans
un format qui équivalent à une taille
lui poussent sur le marché donc on va
pouvoir bénéficier de bord d'
extrêmement fins le cloud cloud j'arrive
pas à nous cacher tous les deux j'ai pas
les bras c'est long et donc format très
frais aux bords très fin et après on va
pouvoir retrouver l'univers samsung en
termes d' usage avec la surcouche ou
animal qu'on connaît qu'on connaît bien
qui permet de naviguer facilement
d'avoir l'usagé humain d'avoir le mode
nuit
tous les bénéfices qu'on connaît sur
live main pour un smartphone google ou
alors du mal à une avec cgg comment mon
pote qui pousse un peu de baume une très
grande
ok nous allons revenir à 3-2 sur
l'ensemble des onze grièvement sur
l'aspect logiciel avec toujours une
offre qui permet de démarrer découvrir
l'univers youtube puisque on a là deux
mois offerts sur l'achat de cette
tablette light auquel quatre mois sur la
ligue 1 ap 6 tab est cet effet très cool
alors ici on est sur un modèle qui est
uniquement wifi wifi avec une
déclinaison 4g la déclinaison kg tandis
que tu me disais sur le modèle f pour
l'instant vous avez uniquement une
version 5 g tout à fait d'accord et
potentiellement on peut imaginer une
version wii fit rêver plus tard voilà
puis là on est sur un aspect de mobilité
on va jouer
l'émergence de ce réseau on est des gens
qui ont envie de la 2d s'évader j'ai
compris en tout en sachant que même si
vous avez une tablette wifi une tablette
cuzon 5 g on peut avoir du rififi garros
et wimbledon
qu'on se rassure pour la maison tout va
bien bon ok ça marche mieux ok ça m'a
donc là on effectivement sur une petite
tablette usage familial
serrez vous êtes série un peu de
navigation mais y met guère mieux
et là c'est vraiment -enfin le confort
c'est vraiment le visionnage c'est plus
la grande table est qu'on va venir
manger on va pouvoir profiter voir ses
vidéos séries préférées dessiner puisque
on a aussi des logiciels qui sont des
offres limitées dans le temps mais qui
permet de découvrir un usage pour
dessiner pour une prise de notes rapides
et voilà précis ça qui les consommateurs
est convaincu et continue et
l'utilisation de ces applications est
ici par contre on peut pas avoir des
restes n avaient qu on peut pas avoir de
la semaine avec ok ça marche j'ai
compris alors qu'il ya une prise jack
qui toujours utile pour pour peut-être
un usage familial ou un pouvoir
connecter son casque alors que sur la
table cet effet on va pouvoir en 8e
ouvrir des voies là en bluetooth
d'alexis boeuf trop ou des galaxies base
line hockey ça marche du monde et vous
avez des cover aussi qui sont versés oui
alors les cover puisque chez nous nous
avons toujours une guerre de cover
associés à un produit
ouais d'accord ici nous avons le clavier
une clavier slim blanc cover clavier ça
vient se poser c'est un menteur et paris
ces aimants télé on va pouvoir protéger
le d'autres sont produits au quai
ensuite rangé élégamment il reste
heureusement son espèce comme ça on
évite de le perdre
et si après bénéficier d'un clavier pour
un usage un peu plus productifs aussi
bien pour une prise de notes rapides
répondre à des mails ou travailler c'est
sûr les élus la mettre dedans que dans
celles qui se posait pas tant que je
peux à mon sens voilà ce que la série a
toujours le risque lié au tour du cercle
je protège pas le jazz il raconté il ya
toujours un risque de
deux chutes alors que là on peut le
ranger ça s'appelle être serein tout au
long de l'utilisation et du transport du
produit aucune faute
donc là petit clavier la cie du coup
infligé parce que je serai version qui
arrive du global mais j'ai encore une
version diamant il y aura un clavier
azerty échoué avec un mode texte qui va
être optimisée et une touche dédiée
et puis après on va re pouvoir avoir les
touches fonctions assez classique ça va
se compliquer
et puis on a également pour un aspect
produit trop de protection lebouc que je
sais des choses il ya du boulot chez moi
cover oui à catherine et dans plusieurs
coloris du bleu du noir du rose
ouais du verre et de l'argent du silver
ouais on va pouvoir choisir en fonction
de son goût la couleur qu'on le préfère
mais on va retrouver sur l'ensemble de
ses coloris la même efficacité en termes
de protection le dos à l'écran le
rangement pour le s pen ouais et sa
ferme et voilà de transporter
efficacement sa tablette très sympa de
la différence et si c'est pas de clavier
réserve clavier exactement en termes de
tarifs on et comment sur ses accessoires
alors sur le bout de leur nez à 69 euros
90 très bien les 70 et puis ici sur le
clavier à -591 d'accord et dans tous les
cas j'ai mon remplacement c'est
exactement ce que j'ai exactement un
pied ici trouvent deux positions pour
plutôt lire ou plutôt regarder une vidéo
pouvoir également utiliser son espen ans
en mode paysage
ok toi que les biens coûteux merci
beaucoup merci à toi voilà donc pour
cette vidéo dites moi ce que vous en
pensez vous comme envie de trouver ces
tablettes est ce que gagnent à une des
deux qui vous ferait de l'oeil plutôt la
table et 7 fo en laissant les fans
edition un peu moins cher mais avec des
supers spec ou est ce qu on est plutôt
sur le modèle un poil plus petits la
table asset light mark et moi tout ça
bien évidemment on bat en commentaire on
en reparlera plus tard on se testera
très probablement la tablette 7 et feu
donc restez connectés abonnez-vous si ce
n'est pas déjà le cas et comme ça vous
serez tous d'ici là portez vous bien des
confusions et de l'amour et surtout a
très vite ciao